good morning good morning how are y'all
and bring our mics up yeah mics up mics
up little less of this hottest game oh
all right mics up pants down game play
leveled hi I'm Peter Brown I'm Rob
handler as he is and we collectively are
the Triforce hmm all right you know we
were we used to do this all the scream
once in a while every week since all the
first came out we're dipping back into
it for master mode the sort of master
mode that was added to breath of the
wild which makes the game a lot more
difficult for many reasons which we've
talked about sure you've heard about
before you probably know yeah but even
tide island is also very hard just in
the regular game of breath of the wild
so we are going to sort of marry those
two things and try to tackle Eventide
Island today in master mode if you don't
know Eventide island takes all your
items away so you go in empty-handed and
you got to do some stuff it yeah you
gotta do some stuff we've done it before
but I I'll be honest I don't know if
this is gonna work out if you cut the
gameplay here you can see I feel like
I'm not well equipped in the stamina
heart range Rob but we are equipped with
positivity and skill and gosh darn it
we've got God on our side if there is
one I bet we do yeah have you been
enjoying master mode so far I've been
enjoying it a lot how do you okay these
floating platforms are something I
really like finding I know that at first
you were skeptical why are they adding
this right makes sense to me right have
your feelings changed at all they have
changed because you want those chests
that's for sure but the other part what
I like is if you approach some of them
they kind of makes one of my gripes was
like as far as the immersion of them
goes they kind of feel like just
bizarre and and not fitting with the
world yeah
what I liked seeing sometimes if you
approach a camp though the guys will be
like on the ground and then when they
see you they engage the octoroks and
like lift up like a lookout post so that
kind of makes sense to a degree as far
as I gotta tell you buddy it's a video
game let's say no I don't you dare I
totally see your point you know we've
we've spent we've all reached triple
digits in terms of hours you played I
don't know close to 400 or more at this
point yeah and I will be modest and say
probably 50 of those hours could've been
you know I wonder if they accounts for
like standby cuz I have left it on and
like you know I mean like when it goes
to sleep well like I'll pause the game
and go to the bathroom you take like a
two-hour don't take this with you to the
bathroom come on
I don't I actually don't I've done it
once and you have a special bathroom
switch yeah what do you do when you're
on the toilet if not play swish I've
been led to believe that's what you do
phone phone live phone Wi-Fi I'll take a
nap in between but yeah if you are if
you're in the chat do acknowledge us
that's literally the last thing in the
chat says notice me senpai in your
creative way of spelling it I'll notice
you Jay not John Bridget navara asks how
many how long have I been at master mode
that's a good question I wish I could
fight well can you find out yeah how
probably when you save your you actually
know you're right there is no ingame
clock right it's all through the system
in you right like it would it would
account for like all of my hours in just
regular mode I don't know if you could
like find out but I mean this village is
so cool this was such an awesome
surprise yeah and we both found it like
100 like over a hundred hours into the
game or like wait a minute yeah yeah it
was Mike it was Micra someone Indian
like yeah he hit us up and he was like
dude there's this like beach town I mean
like get out and I just like had to find
it yeah I came from like up there just
paraglide two down it was majestic I
this makes me want to go on vacation
I've I've gone on a few vacations like
to places that I know I like to like oh
yeah just go Japan eat some food bicycle
stuff I want to go to like it a place
like this where it's just Beach and
water and drinks and do nothing except
get sunburned yeah right I could use
some of this life damn crap I just
realized horses can't swim of course
can't swim I should have done the other
route
just ditch this horse yeah yeah send it
into the drink I'm kind of close can you
stasis it and blow it up and have it go
so here's another as you uh my baby you
get a little Apple it says my perfect
baby I love feeding horses
I love eating horses whoa horse meat of
course meat bones so I wanted to also
say something though
eyes as you can notice here chat I got
five hearts and not a whole lot of
stamina but what else I don't have is
the upgraded stasis oh yeah work I know
I know
so I spent I spent a long time last
night trying to like get shrines etc etc
I was going into shrines like minor
tasks of strengths I just turning around
nope like that's what's what about this
mode sorry I mean giving up giving up
and being terrified even with this mask
like I was telling you like I'm pretty
sure high-level enemies actually you
know the I want to see that cuz when I
was using it I didn't run into anything
that was giving me any trouble
look I know Lionel's react to you I know
skeletons the story actually but yeah I
got to see it yeah to believe it
like I we have what I was saying you
know as you know like this this mask can
like you know basically disguise you
from all monsters there are some what
well you know not Lionel's and guardians
but for the most part all of them but I
had ran a run into like a high-level
enemies I swear to god dude they like
looked at me for a second and then game
on
but yeah again we're gonna get rocked
I'm scared and I'm scared in the sense
that I would hate for this dream to end
and just utter defeat but that's okay
wouldn't be the first yeah yeah so again
thank you for joining us yes please have
a live stream every day at 11 a.m.
find at YouTube on Twitch pretty easy to
find and we mix things up on Tuesdays
we've got the lobby it's our live show
or me this guy Michael Hardy and Callie
plaguey we talk about the latest stuff
in gaming and otherwise we've got people
like Jean Luc psyche and Joey playing
whatever the hell floats their boat
pretty much last last week they did Deal
or No Deal on the Nintendo DS and like
actually had Deal or No Deal of chat
yeah it was it was actually really they
really went all out and did a lot of
prep it was pretty awesome yeah other
streams include just you know whatever
is new will usually unlike what
Tuesday's will play brand new games for
a bit okay so here we go we've got some
enemies here that are mid to high-level
right yeah I mean I could have been
wrong I could have just like
accidentally killed one but it was you
know so that's you can't you call these
Wednesday's yes goob lobbies on the
Wednesday I don't know what I said are
these like like I know there's like
silver I don't know what color Oats
would be brown is it like black there's
their black level is that I don't know
if they're fames it's silver just
straight I thought yeah I thought it all
the silvers have rabies
remember this when times were not rough
this is nice yes sneak King tomorrow
they're gonna play that mother-effing
Burger King game where he plays a creepy
Burger King mascot sneak you know are
they suburbs
God my brother so funny when we were
growing up he had just like the weirdest
not taste but he would just play what he
could get yeah I think you could get
that out of Burger King or something
right yeah there was like three
different games that Burger King was
offering for the original Xbox and ps2 I
believe
sneaking being the one that caught on
because let's face it it's a really
weird thing that you're doing you could
do in real life but you really shouldn't
added to the fact that you're playing as
a as a king looking mascot with a static
expression on his face it just reeks of
like serial killer like an 80s ya horror
movie but comedy hold on wait a minute
so I did this last time did you get
stuck in the ocean no it just took a
real long time should I did I pick up
the wrong listen where yeah let me see
your man like a paw cuz you can get a
raft here right I don't know like what's
the best question I wouldn't usually go
yeah for the raft cuz you can get one
you could get a wrap or you would have
to swim out there you can get a raft
around here but there's also one here
okay so we saw a black book table and
then it's silver and then it's gold got
it
so maybe silver Thank You Navarro thank
you I don't know what the hell I'm doing
sweet should I go here and just
paraglide it's just kind of waste of
time yeah sorry guys
should have had this figured out yeah I
was up pretty late last night like in
denial I could get a fair amount
well originally we want it so we're
thinking about we're definitely gonna
play this all the way through to ganon
yeah and so we're thinking about doing
bits and pieces so you know hopefully
next stream I gotta have was the 13
hearts to get the sword yeah we could
try master mode on Charles child's sword
and that will also go real well so I'm
thinking if we can get the sword right
get to 13 hearts get the sword if we can
successfully complete the trials then
that's the point where we go fight get
it we don't do the dungeons we don't do
any of that so we wind up at Ganon's
front door and at the door of the divine
beasts or whatever you know the demons
habet them yeah with a part of us i
think either either way we're gonna stop
hard
oh are you gonna have enough stamina I'm
not so I'm thinking about a raft there's
got to be where I go for the raft damn
overcast come in
I love doing the peril at a last second
oh yeah all banned you should kill that
just for fun just show off kill what
this the guy who's hiding but go Jenna
no way like with a sword I was saying
plummet into him Oh like from real high
I god no I don't have an hour well we do
know that would have killed him from
that height I don't think so dude there
so there's so high level all right so
much for a raft and it's really been on
one don't remember all right I did this
for my first time nope it's alright
so yeah you know thinking about the mass
or the armor that came with this DLC and
it actually makes a lot of sense as far
as the majoras and the the phantom armor
how you can get that pretty quickly
right it's a good stat boost on the
phantom armor like it right away
yeah like and it's pretty vital and
makes sense as far as just surviving in
those early phases because as you and I
realized the first time that first spoke
hobbling you get by the old man we just
he's got a run by him and most other
problems and just get those first runes
and as well the paraglider pretty image
but still doesn't matter because my god
our dudes a tough out screw that up
i so i also last and i was like you know
i want to get the Hylian Shield yeah and
i got as far as that stale knocks yeah
oh my god i thought i'll I got pretty
close but I couldn't finish him I ran
out of weapons because I'm fairly sure
and maybe check and like clarify I'm
pretty sure weapons are faster less
durable yeah it seems that way I looked
that up didn't and I couldn't find any
confirmation so I don't know if that's
the case it might not be that the
weapons themselves are breaking the
enemies are stronger yeah like yeah
maybe somehow their defense rating plays
into how it breaks
yeah so while we're doing this are you
are you gonna play splatoon are you
looking forward to that I am looking
forward to it I've never played the
first one yeah I played a little too the
single-player so far but I am
dammit I am more interested with
multiplayer as you would expect
yeah the single-player stuff which is
all that we can really talk about right
now is pretty good it like that alone
feels better than the first game yeah
just having an on switch feels I I'm
still surprised every time I realize
what the ingenious system this is yeah
and it's you know it's funny too because
if you look back at Sony they like try
to do the similar thing with the PSP at
one point like I've had video out so you
could plug it into your TV if a game is
working that level yes Pico they had a
plug and play what yeah yeah the games
looks like ps1 games at best at the time
when ps2 was getting old
so yeah it's splatoon too just feels
like I gave up on splatoon because I
didn't like playing with the Wii U I
really hated that gamepad just
everything about it felt cheap it and
just under done and it would get really
gross very easily for some reason so yes
like the texture of it I guess like I'm
more of a matte guy yeah so all around
I'm just loving the switch and it's it's
nice to be back in splatoon - yeah
everyone can I guess this weekend if
they're interested in the game it's
going to be that public open multiplayer
beta let's do this yeah that's it's it's
really interesting how they have those
excuse me is it even open beta like
that's just open it's a server test it's
it's crazy how short that window is
though yeah what is it like like three
four hours to think I don't know I think
it's a couple it's it's definitely a
handful of hours it might be two days
this weekend I could be wrong it made my
Jess be one that shrine has a it's a
modest test I believe the one that we
were just at or is it's that one up
there I can't remember no I think it's
major I remember like when I was playing
this game I probably I'd like I don't
know eight hearts might just run and
hitting that shrine and being like yep
nope I'll be back
the group wants to know if we're playing
anything else I switch Mario Kart good a
good amount of it but I don't know why I
stopped it wasn't a brand new game right
it was it was great to play the game but
I think it's not new
I still haven't played too much arms
which I'm a little I'm a little sad
about you know yeah I have even gotten
it yeah no I don't have it either that's
that's what's stopping me yeah I'm
playing a lot of the Neo Geo games whoa
don't rock the boat baby don't know man
regen okay so a key tip here right is to
try to get a save I believe on land
before the Eventide challenge engages
right like so if you can get on this
rock maybe yeah it's like the first rock
hopefully it works
those damn lose all those don't come
back all right please for the love of
God was holding on to the rock you know
what that means
gotta be that one go oh and I didn't
what so I was as you know with the the
trials someone had the idea we realize
that you can you can bring you can't
bring in obviously all your like
materials and gear up and you can cook
but you can cook and you can prep before
and I was hoping to get like the
additional or folk recovery plus twelve
hearts and an attack bonus you know well
looked up that's pretty imperative let's
look at it this way right and I have two
hearts missing you're either gonna beat
this or you're gonna die if you die you
get a chance to try again so you can do
all that stuff just go back to your last
save Oh actually where that last save
was so the problem is that actually we
take you back yeah it's deceiving it's
not gonna be on a raft cuz isn't that
the same problem if you save while
holding on to a rock you have to
actually be standing on it that's what
that's why I was trying to stand because
I was suspicious of rent as well yeah
moist officio so um let's see yeah
that's a good question I wonder if
they're gonna change up the enemies that
are on what damn those guys are super
easy to kill thankfully yeah you're
right
gah it's also super easy today one heart
hey I believe me
now as I feel I think he comes back I
don't think you can drown a skull what
you can drown a book hobbling but not a
skeleton no no you did okay where's your
arm have you seen the nope he's back
okay
nope maybe you can't guys a
rollercoaster of emotion here everybody
it was so creepy but cool the first time
I saw a skeleton head like bite and roll
its way up a cliff yeah so now we
scavenge because my health ain't so hot
now I have no book haba arm vocab arm
get them while they're hot
so you can just throw those and set
people on fire is all right okay it's
like do some you gotta you gotta set
them off but yeah that could be useful
someone asks if I've been Ganon I be
yeah we both did on regular but the plan
again if you're just joining us we're
gonna we're gonna do a few parts as far
as uh playing this on master mode we're
gonna you know try to see if we can beat
this on master and then you know
throughout the blog feed so this is the
best part but this island what I realize
is mighty bananas my man cook those and
you get a nice you add a little mighty
Fissel a little dragon horn tally me up
bananas do you got yourself a nice
30-minute triple attack buff hot recipe
yeah but you it's it helps if you can
stay alive to use it
yeah that's fine I wanted to know I
didn't like that say so are you gonna
try to cook well I really want that save
but so can you have the item intensive
of all the preps the one thing I did
Peter as I made some so oh I got some
stuff here and a decent well I could
even use what would be more you want
health dude cuz you're gonna dive well
what buff attacker defense
Oh defense really yeah alright that's
what I would do I mean if I didn't
really make any of those
what's the death count up to one one
death Bob back again with the death
count Bob's a cool name
is Bob your formal name isn't Bobby you
and I when I was a baby I was pretty
chubby and when I began first began to
crawl I didn't move my back legs I would
just drag myself like I was in the
military or something anyways the family
coined me as a Big Bob and then cut to
me trying to think the cool thing to do
for freshman year of high school was to
change my name up I tried changing my
name to fake Bob thinking I could like
be hella sick yeah dude that's how dumb
I was it didn't stick except for one guy
kept calling me looking big today Bob
all right well let's play it safe you do
you man yeah I mean ultimately I'm not
playing here so whatever you need saving
just for the hell of it man I mean I
don't like how there's no I mean there's
no auto safes I guess right or just one
auto save and one heart save is all you
get I guess yeah I found that find that
like unnecessarily difficult like you
don't I mean like I don't know why can't
I can't have those auto saves those like
the only reason I would wanna in case I
did something really dumb and like drop
the shield I got Hylian Shield or
something yeah
okay all right I just do it now
and then save I could always use another
[Music]
kind of hearts that's right and Pfeiffer
wants to know the differences between
master and normal you have enemies that
are stronger you have as in the tier of
enemies raises right already become
blues right and so forth
you've got new treasure chests placed
around the world I feel like there's so
many things I'm forgetting I just like
can't think of it right now
yeah treasure chest those these boat
octo rock lifts where enemies will kind
of attack from above which also have
chests that you can eat or eat yeah I
mean primarily the biggest difference is
enemies will kill you with greater
efficiency than ever there are there are
more changes that are a little bit more
subtle but that still have lasting
impact but we are stupid and can't
remember them yeah what else there's got
a couple other ones Bob Jones there is
not like a new tier of colored enemy
necessarily everything is just more
difficult and that's kind of just works
you sort of ramp up your concept of what
they can do it's not gonna work
it's up will matter welcome to the
stream we are the travelers this is not
gonna work it'll work
it's gonna be right when I stand there
is an area I have done it is that a
standing now game did you eat the food
you ate the food yeah I did
let's see if it works I don't know it
did for travel distort I would expect
it's like a similar I don't know what
you call like a script right like these
are very similar travel disorder terms
of stripping you everything's right I'm
spitting you out
yeah sick oh I can't save here can i
well that at least worked
James dingos asking me if we played this
game for the story I would say the best
part about this game are the incredible
side quests and shrine quests even
that's one of the reasons why I've put
so much time is because they are the
just the stories and those stories in
particularly yeah like it's not even
like it's some of the best ones that I
have personally don't even revolve
around combat it's just like helping a
town or town and stuff but other
situations like it's just unexpected
things right like that guy in the bridge
like if you stand on the ledge you know
at first you he's like whoa don't jump
and you're like oh this character
doesn't want people to take their own
lives he's very thoughtful and like
intend to thought to make a character
like that but then the guy reveals that
like I don't want you to jump because
that would ruin my day because it'd be
really awkward for me to see you do that
so just don't make it weird for me okay
little stuff like that but to your point
I do think that the main story damned to
go the main story in this game is is not
a strength I actually don't know that I
would call this a great Zell
because I think this is all the stuff in
it is tacked on more or less but if you
look at like what Nintendo has done with
the Mario series right they take some
you know characters in a world we know
and love and they sort of inject it with
new mechanics new types of game design
and I feel like that's what's happened
here at breadth of the wild and I really
love that and you can actually largely
avoid this story you know the main story
in this game you don't have to beat the
dungeons and those dungeons are the
primary link primary link to anything
beyond just hey I woke up I need to save
Hyrule by beating ganon I mean you can
literally expose yourself to the story
I'm pretty sure with just that and
that'll be all you'll get but you could
still play this game for hundreds of
hours as I'm sure you know yeah and yeah
so a my opinion as far as stories go
really weak in this game but I also
don't think it tried very hard so I
didn't feel like it wasted a lot of my
time so I was okay with it mm-hmm it's
pretty long-winded answer no that was
well said this is scary
there's an axe here but I think I'm
gonna screw this up no I won't into the
drink yeah you guys stay positive man
that almost didn't go well stop sorry
for yelling what is your favorite Zelda
game and I miss okay wait
before I ask you this real will matter
do you mean including breath of the wild
or other than breath with a while yeah
oh we will let you know that
I wish though ere they lost a little bit
of help when they were burned like they
don't really seem to tak buff is good I
chose the attack buff because it's three
levels of this of my 1/2 minute defense
long Oh another thing I just remembered
enemies will notice you from much
farther oh yeah yeah and smarter in
general like low level bow cobble ins I
feel like the first to like red and blue
guys like whatever in the heat of the
moment I'm just gonna munch on something
they feel like SWAT bombs you know I
mean like the silvers will like take a
bomb even at you yeah but I felt like I
feel like most Volkov ones at any level
will like do that now okay so the answer
the question is including breath of the
wild what is your favorite Zelda game
well it's either this or Ocarina of Time
I don't know I can't stress enough how
how much like I don't know in my time
here at GameSpot I have never played or
wanted to play a game so consistently a
non-stop yeah like it's it's become
damaging like there are other things we
should be doing here or playing and I'm
like it's like a it's tough I don't know
it's the one game I can keep going back
like yeah that's not your rocket League
is also included in that but it I I
compared it to something like Grand
Theft Auto where there it was there was
a time when if you didn't have any game
to play you had no problems and even if
you did have a new game to play you had
no problems turning on Grand Theft Auto
and screwing around because it was fun
unexpected things could happen and you
felt like you were sort of it was either
a difference of you being control or not
being in control until you know
navigating that sort of experience with
the game
was a lot of fun and that applies to
this as well I think this may be the
best game with the name Zelda attached
to it but if I was going to personally
choose a game that I think is the best
quintessential Zelda game that would be
linked to the Past for me ocarina is
great I sadly haven't played Majora's
Mask I know I actually haven't either
dude I haven't played stream that then
yeah we probably should did alright
actually that's a great idea done
horrible you know what let's quit this
game [ __ ] it
load it up those bananas look rotten
yeah they do all right
all right Peter uh yes Robert I'm
praying to God that I don't die cuz I
was a lot of work oh dude those are fast
yeah there you go there you go don't
shoot me I want you to do it shoot me
shoot me I want to do it nailed it
yeah okay so we should we pull out the
old 64 for that or is it worth doing
like a like that well the 3ds right had
that remaster yeah I'm thinking the 3ds
we can also do 64 if you'd like it's
just the 64 now image isn't that good
and we can get HDMI 3d s games going so
I'm thinking the 3d s1 but let's talk
about it I just wouldn't prefer to do it
handheld I don't know something weird
about that no you're right actually
that's a good point I mean we could look
at the screen but we would have to hold
all right let's do 64 version yeah I
just wonder how we should we'll test it
and see how it looks
all right plan I've attack all right
well here's the thing so we got three of
these shrine balls that's with her call
shrine Bob we should we do the hardest
first no no good no I'd damn it's tough
because if we die are you gonna be more
depressed having accomplished nothing or
more depress having losing the
accomplishments you have made Frost we
noticed you I'm always aware of you you
I don't that's a good question I'm just
well I'm also thinking about this attack
buff I have I'm not gonna get much
better than this so maybe use the six
minutes wisely somewhere they follow
your heart man like the if your mind by
the side of the road and follow your
heart into the horizon he's don't even I
had to cook them huh I thought roasting
could ward could release that attack
aroma all right let's rock this smells
like ginger yeah do it come down it's a
party this guy Robert do you have a
favorite race in the franchise a
favorite race yeah and you can't say
white people
this is rosado's auras gowron's Rito's
like the read over I like to read Oh
bird kids I like them all to him it I
like them all I don't see race that was
the correct answer no arrows I don't
know maybe read oh I like gorons I like
their i like their their tape clothes
their tastes and uh Nam joen Oh their
taste in a trombone I like that favorite
weapon masks Chris Hatter the master
sword upgraded is awesome I still
haven't played with that because I still
haven't beat the trials someone's
telling us there's a metal to be just
our fate chased our face there's a metal
chest inside the pond nearby we'll get
there my boil chest in the pond yeah
zooks
use the bomb because then you can get
their bow and arrow
oh no office bomb no I have to like
electrocute him oh damn it
oops his health stop regen Inge if I had
to pick I'm all about the group the
Gerudo I think yeah they're pretty
awesome
Amazon's baby
my ab own arm stronger than an axe
non-master
I'm thinking that ancient weapons yeah
look you know it's kinda hard to think
about that right now
the socked a god I have to focus on my
guy gasps god damn dude favorite armor
set enjoy the process like how how Peter
should I just ignore these dudes yeah no
I don't think you can Oh No
can you light that stick on fire and
then set them on fire somehow maybe I
should get out of the fire
I don't know if that'll help no no none
of this [ __ ]
said Rob your love he needs it
[Music]
yeah I mean you could literally just
hurt yourself we all know please be a
weapon look at you with all your arrows
so I guess that's kind of part of it
right like my my um you know what screw
this dude what an animal I'm taking your
[ __ ] oh my god one time I got all the
way if this took me so long to do the
for my first go what time I got all the
way to the end Oh an octorok oh he's
gonna be prong I got old like the last
ball shrine in it something happened
where like it I lost it come on come on
it like went just too far out to where
you couldn't actually get it yeah all
right whoa God oh yeah so there's a
chest in that little pun oh use a little
Magnus's you know I'm saying yeah the
old tug and pull yeah just ignore them I
gotta ignore those guys I thanks
Sebastian I for the confirmation and I
think that's a good call yeah cuz that's
that's a it's the same problem when you
first start master mode is uh you start
with a stick you're not gonna do any
damage there's gonna regen you have to
like have some powerful enough that can
knock them out
don't you gotta push the ball out there
first how did we do this last time
nope oh my baby oh all right
valuable baby don't fall off well there
goes my attack buff thanks for nothing
sorry I'll make that throw you can
definitely make that throw I can play it
safe you definitely should not play it
safe
heave oh I'll take a birdie doctor
that's a whole lid was yeah 90% master
mode is avoiding enemies yeah agreed
all right okay cool cool margin for
anyone who watches the lobby cool uh
yeah
cool all right doesn't maybe that's not
true he's not in today
I didn't see him today you then huh oh
he's key you can't like he had to throw
the farmer seriously pharmacy pharmacy
more like buying crack in an alley oh no
yep see this Peter deception for it and
also an [ __ ] what up go back to that
pond yeah definitely what can you do
with an octave balloon that would make
sense here Mike was in chat [ __ ] you
heard me
what's the other 10% this pond oh there
it is yes nice thanks thanks chat real
helpful it was not sarcastic what were
you asking uh what you really think of
Michael Hardy is whatever that's good I
think he's a hell of a cool dude
Wow yeah he has a real neutral smell
which is also suspicious right yeah I
try and I try
ooh to figure out what the hell Michael
Hardy smells like because you can't it's
impossible yeah I don't know I don't
know what I don't know what that says
about me about him about the state of
the world but
three arrows
he's like walking no gonna say it's like
what no he's like chalk just like chalk
chalk does not react does really have a
smell does it well maybe I don't know
what how do they make chalk is it just
cocaine is it he has it is it crack
without the crack which I had my god
damn it Joe
oh no I didn't want me doing nope he
don't know you don't see me actually I
want arrows I wish you could burn trees
down like it'd be cool if you could just
bribe for its oh damn sorry nobody's
saying nothing I just talking about
arson yeah oh I should really eat well
oh I should move like to have a good
amount of whoa
dang Oh Rock you should go drop a metal
thing up there so they get struck my
lady what metal thing
ushido if you can get up there somehow
into pot and drop your show for a second
no like do much I tried that the other
day but they'll drop their weapons ah
well I want my shield they don't you're
in a rainstorm we're gonna invite her
well it's gonna pass yeah but you'll get
it back oh it doesn't no idear
okay I'll bail here's a present oh [ __ ]
no no no go back ooh if you run away
long enough they might return I think I
just got a text message I wonder if it's
from Mike mo Hardy no it's not Mike
Marty
darienne's leaf I'll get the leaf yeah I
guess you guys are rocking the leaf on
yeah but what's up a belief well you can
push them back I guess
[Music]
one more arrows
like look at there
maybe there's a limit to how many you
can get out of them I'm gone
this is not doing are you talking about
yourself
no this dude he's just having a blast
he just loves that horn
Frost is saying you can give them the
leaf I don't know that they would use
that over there there's an interesting
idea yes
uh-oh don't miss miss let's try this
little leaf out I'm worried I have
concerns
[Music]
I'll use it you know it'll it'll be
useful up here there's a bunch of dudes
let's move on I'm stalling I'm not gonna
kill this bastard
also this is not gonna be oh hey baby
he states drop tree-sweet okay so can
you use those to your advantage do you
plan to use those to your advantage
[Music]
nice yes all right
rain stopped okay so this one's gonna be
real difficult because I have to use
stasis push the Oh duh usually the
Bushmen in the water frost also saying
use bees you grab the honeycomb so it
would distract them so you can at least
get the work I already did it or oh
these guys though I can't like move bees
I can't like if you carry the honey come
over your head they don't follow you no
and they would also hurt me
alright plan of attack here not do that
because this one's like the hardest in
my opinion because you have to stasis to
lift up that like oh the plate the plate
or whatever and we had problems last
time doing that but so I mean basically
active so I can't like I can't avoid
these guys I feel like yeah you may have
to kill them but if you can or if you
can knock them off the cliff into the
water the bomb however you can do that
like get them to chase you
it won't be easy yeah it won't be easy
but the other good thing right now is
it's night time and I feel like they're
gonna go to sleep well some of them will
right yeah but that lookout man he's
gonna find you ah Jerry Montoya wants to
know do you all like cheese mm-hmm a big
cheese guy mm-hmm
I'm eating cheese right now stored
something I'll see it yeah it's like a
cow keeps like you know that the cut or
the shed you call it that lump of grass
in your cheek they just chew on is it
okay we didn't kid cudi came from this
guy doesn't see me he can smell you
you know something tasty is out there
smells like a here damn I chose rush
this dude yeah Oh get him off the cliff
you got to get down there get him off
cliff he's gonna blow that horn
nice eat cliff and stay out he doesn't
get back up here he can't I think you
had to climb right up you say you should
be quiet snipe him in the head if you
have arrows it's sniping doesn't really
do much at this point I mean if I get a
good like critical shot I don't know if
it'll kill him well I have a pretty good
bow actually now oh you know what I did
forgot that shield [ __ ] my language he's
got good stuff blow him up oh you know
what a happy tur oh let's try that leaf
No
and of those of arrows oh I was really
proud to work there you go oh there you
go be somebody get something you know
that swords gonna break in like five
sweets
run and dump run and dumb piece octo
balloons on the plate I think we were
trying that last time and someone had
this idea that like I don't know what it
was
remember the last time we tried it and
we like messed up Oh
what oh that's fine it was actually like
tough to get that plate up in particular
for some reason this is going pretty
well dude I didn't want to say anything
but yes it is what you do with my
friends I'm on your side I'm undercover
I know Zelda all right let's try this
guy's all the cold she said don't worry
about it I'm fine don't need you anymore
yeah just got the funnel hold on one sec
I'm talking to sell that yeah her Ned's
our guy yeah I guess they're a thing now
Stella says you stink so you don't have
any ambition damn use all those whatever
was I gonna say trap nano be really cool
would like a knock if this would like
step on man Oh denied pop oh wow
what he took this post back I get back
up here he didn't necessarily die
Oh f-you no no watch last night mmm
dragnet yeah is it good no oh he was on
that podcast that you showed me oh sure
it has some moments but then like you
watch it and you're like either this
script sucks or they edited it to hell
there's like seem to scene line to line
things feel very disjointed but bad it's
funny to watch Tom Hanks like play these
different roles because we all have this
idea of him now as a very mature
whatever he is like the Turk off like
playboy like [ __ ] so here's what we
do here's what we do we go to that first
you owe me a play was it the dragnet
talk that did it alright alright so
here's all right that's fine that's fine
you know how to do this do this yeah
because the thing is now is you just
survived an hour nobody been silent like
that's pretty good
damn dude that wasn't that was his foot
that was his foot to my face what could
you have done differently what did we
learn just distance and also like I was
trying to like what I was trying to do
was I know I think there was a heavy I
was a heavy sword I believe it's a
claymore I don't know but generally two
hits on a mob will like make them fall
yeah not that time not that
Bob Jones saying sneak attack the big
guys sneak attacks are effectively
gimped in this in mass well they don't
they don't just kill an enemy
automatically like they were you can get
you can get like half their health off
yeah I believe it's just a video an
Astra mode but it's not just him at the
moment you wake him up everyone else
it's sad we should go there first
for us to saying you can drop weapons
and items onto the plate and then
trigger you've been tied up and take
them off the boat
but the boat doesn't stay does it we've
seen try it with something that you
won't mind losing but that'll still be
effective so you sail the boat onto the
island almost completely then you drop
your weapon so I'm pretty sure actually
there's somewhere you can stand everyone
say the boat trick works on the boat or
like put on the ground or I'll try it
it's nice try it while not moving that's
it that's a good pointer well a
boomerang will be cool yeah boomerang
would be cool yeah no way this guy's
going to attack me there's no way I'm
really a dinosaur little kid
boomerang will be good yeah
God I don't care that was my eyes level
jump dude oh my god
use your Magnus's to get that back I
doubt it oh man watch this for days that
sound effect of it dropping yeah
boomerang would be good
saved I can get the Boomer on get that
boomer on gonna make that
how you doing son I have to go pay must
have had me about 13 dr. peppers all
right
alright alright okay hey man there was
one Rock you can save it on dude
man and we were talked about the Forrest
Gump sequel Gump and son well there's a
book right yeah yeah I read it in like I
don't know fourth grade and the only
thing I can remember is that him and his
son devised a way to like energize clean
energy from pig [ __ ] and so they had
this farm and they've like kidding it
out with all this stuff to like prove
that like yes we can process oh dude no
sorry figure of note so I got it nice in
case I die but I won't yeah keep going
so you learn how to process you know
natural manure or whatever and turn it
into fuel and so they invite the town
the government all these peoples like
hundred people at their farm for a proof
of concept thing
well of course Forest Gump is kind of an
idiot and he forgot to turn the pressure
valve open so at the time when everyone
was at the farm to see this thing there
was really exciting huge scientific
breakthrough everything explodes and
[ __ ] gets all over everyone and rather
than understand they just go out for
blood and they just want to hunt down
Forrest Gump and son so they're like on
the run at night helicopters chasing
it's like so bizarre so bizarre and I
could be misremembering some of this
because this was 22 years ago but yeah
yeah that's really bizarre it's funny
thing cuz you know a lot of that movie
is like he's so unfortunate it's so
funny think like you know on the sequel
I'm going all out this guy gets too busy
really I'm pretty shy makes sense it
doesn't make sense but it does I mean
with all the stuff he did man she didn't
feel so good damn dude should I do this
again and drop like a lot more stuff
what time we got twelve o'clock right
now so yeah your seat is pretty close
right
right mm-hmm you just press your lips up
getting the microphone for all you at
home boy I gotta make a move don't I
yeah let's do it
so Diego RC arse is saying the 14 damage
spoken insta-kill Bluebook habla with a
headshot sneak attack so they don't see
you come in instant death sorry guys I
just didn't that that's a really good
trick
once again we head for Eventide island
and for anyone just joining us my name
is Peter Brown this is Robert handler II
we are GameSpot's Triforce we'd like to
play Zelda and we try to come up with
excuses to do it on stream for you guys
did you like hanging out with you today
we are playing master mode which is the
very high difficulty setting that was
added to Zelda not too long ago breath
of the wild and we are trying to do
Eventide island which is a it's an
island you have to complete a task but
you're stripped of all your weapons and
items which in the face of the higher
difficulty makes it much more difficult
but the chat was kind enough to inform
us of a cheat so we are going to cheat
our way to victory because we have no
shame and yeah and this is game spots 11
o'clock stream today day every day we
have a stream at 11 o'clock it changes
Wednesdays is the lobby Tuesdays would
be probably a brand new game that came
out that week Monday you can watch is
that way
Monday is Joey and John Leuchars that's
that is Jake and Mike Jake and Mike
they're gonna be playing battlegrounds
yes and then Friday tomorrow you can
join for Joey and Joe excite bu their
stream is very fun they play weird stuff
but the flimsiest of pretense and so
thank you for joining us today we are
gonna play for their half hour so far
however long it takes us to be Eventide
and only now that we're cheating and we
can probably do it this feels cheap
should I not do it oh it's okay hear me
out
you put forth an incredible effort you
got very far it took an hour right
[Laughter]
gone maybe
so we can limit this right you can get
one melee weapon one ranged weapon and
one shield that sounds great we'll do
that sounds great middle Rob that's what
I'm calling romaine yeah the main thing
I wanted was a bow to be honest damn it
I love it get up
I really wish they would add underwater
stuff to this game you imagine if it was
just like oh yeah by the way all the
bodies of water in the game you can now
explore it like I don't think it back to
like no man's sky ooh which have you
heard that no man's sky is doing this
crazy arg right now when that it might
add vented reality game all right so I'm
gonna totally change topics here no
man's sky developers hello games they've
started this thing called like the Atlas
group or the Atlas something and you
have no idea it's related to no man's
sky really it's just a sort of thing you
hear about you don't know it's about no
man's sky now so that's probably how you
will find it but you can sign up for
these different things and eventually
you have to take like a survey it's like
how do you feel about the nature of
reality how do you feel about the nature
of right versus wrong things like that
no man sky is a game that was a lot of
people expected all these like huge
exploration and sort of social things to
happen really the most interesting part
about it was following the Atlas path so
whatever they're doing they're gonna
expand on that to a degree but they also
are asking questions about or presenting
ideas where it's like two people exist
on different planes in the same universe
so maybe there will start to maybe this
is the thing that will give people those
interactions that they miss the first
time around and expand on the eyeless
path what I'm saying is no man's sky
might be relevant again before we know
it damn dude yeah
and there's been a lot of things added
to the game as well yeah like Rovers and
stuff
yeah and building your own bases and
things like that very curious to see
that yeah definitely yeah because they
you know they really needed well I don't
know how them like if that will save you
know the unfortunate scorn that they
receive yeah I would I would definitely
say it's unfortunate that game was it
did some really interesting stuff
anything the cheat works if you do it
properly picked oh that's that's cool
guys okay alright okay
should have parked this boat a little
closer on OJ and people are saying you
lose the items after you I don't care I
saw that too so yeah that's all the guys
I don't care all right yeah
Rob's too cool for that [ __ ] okay it's
for the good of a stream do it for you
guys
[Music]
alright Eventide alright it's a new boy
in town oh my god there's a fire
soon after he does it and see ya but you
think you could do that again a little
less but like a little less or something
no no got it no no arrows so alternately
you can put the items back on the boat
before you guys get that you to do what
might shoot you in
yeah
Kendi don't these look good
kinda kind of look like tasty gummies
man I miss you being able to eat candy
freely serious so I was chasing a boy
and lightning happened fried the boy and
I've had a real good snack oh wow I
think we'll be able to go yeah I think
so too
we don't do it you might never see you
again
doesn't say anywhere that's stupid hat
for good luck don't even see it you know
it's weird it shows up randomly Eric
jerk oh yeah here we go let's do this
can you use that treasure chest yeah I
mean at this point I'm gonna rock these
guys you can see [ __ ] dude Oh Robbie's
having R&B career yeah good one Pete no
no you said something good job
hello yeah shut the hell up
sweat on I'm back this song sucked I
know that
yeah my
yeah at some point he's guys are like
they were giving him arrows no no no
nobody firing yeah those arrows were
already there
no he's just spazzing out keep firing
all right boys oh [ __ ] no I'm going one
more
real deal
okay so you are on track we are ten
minutes into our lot in half hour you've
got the first one all right
[Music]
this parts boring
I have the key I'm the keymaster are you
the gatekeeper that bird is really
annoying
someone thinks in a chat that it's not
cool to cheat I kind of grieve but we
also someone else set it very
aggressively there we have one hour
which I also agree with because at some
point Peter we need to eat food
yeah also it's cool if we do what we
want to do so just be real we're having
fun
amen you know what you're right
nope damn my bow never like make that
you can make it I don't know I don't
know you can totally make it yeah you're
right dude you're so right
god you guys are such dicks usually the
most annoying enemy in this game wow I'm
wasting arrows I don't care
next up camp camp
yeah I can't wait for these Star Wars
movie what service oh my god Peter
I think there's gonna be a trailer next
week I really hope so
I'm I'm looking forward to as well I'm
nervous I'm definitely a little nervous
you know what I mean
oh yeah for sure I mean I do know you
mean oh these guys again I do know
exactly what you mean like we've we've
gotten past the initial you know the
starting line we're Star Wars is back
yes the redemption yeah and even rogue
one was like who Star Wars is back but
different but yes but I don't know yeah
nope--like like that's part of the car
sasha is cool right but that was even
though you could say a piece of the
force awakens that was a weakness was
that it lean so heavily on structural a
new home storytelling this object yeah
so so in that sense they gotta gotta
bring something new to the table I mean
what they what they're doing really is
the story right like I think that is
sort of the big deal is what's up with
the Jedi what's up at Luke that's gonna
that's gonna be good but well everything
around it also be good just really the
whole movie won't be just ray and Luke
talking about lore and [ __ ] like that
that'll be great what the rest of it I
don't know I have fun looking into
camera in strange ways Vineyard
playing so I entertain myself I don't
think you have to see any other Wow
lucky for you kind of handle this wrong
as far as started this no it's just a
it's a different right way there's no
wrong
shut your mouth oh yeah oh wow
[Music]
storm's a-brewin
[Music]
like that mob ones close man dude you're
gonna get zapped and your bow to this
hit the Royal is the Royal gear not
maybe it's made from some sort of thank
you nope it's my heart my heart just
skipped
can you get up top on that thing that do
you any good
put the post oh my god that scared the
crap out of me
sure let's go up here
oh the edges will ya rekt enter just
took all that is I thought it you drop
oh I thought it was wooden it is is it
so I don't have upgrade stasis Frost
right oh look at wait did that book
hobbling I'm sorry bobland die
I never know he did good because that
guy was it man if you try if you oh like
the shield I'm wearing no okay I don't
need this
yeah yeah
come on yes always be bombing I guess oh
where the hell that come from dude oh
good yeah
and I really don't like these guys also
don't like the weather right now time
Airlines you try it again
no no what should I do it you could wait
out the weather No
can you do anything with that barrel
like leave a bomb next to it and have
them chase you and then blow it up and
they get close it seems that Xena could
be a one guys almost dead Oh two of them
you got one oh he got burned cool
weather is done you can use your [ __ ]
tight whatever you can hold one hand all
right boys
oh there's a cooking pot there ass good
news hey [ __ ] yeah your boy I just
took his guts how do you feel about that
nailed it
hello ah all right what's the best trick
here beater you've got what's the
highest damage isn't even about highest
damage like what is it oh I know to do
get it from this angle
do bones yes
[Music]
all right not what I was trying to do
should just act it from the top about it
all right
Enochs time right yeah my only concern
is that on top where the where the key
or we're like the shrine keyhole is yeah
there's a bunch of dudes so it's like
should I take them out first and just
get over with and then sneak the he
knocks probably right dozen I have to
like yeah yeah as well do it while the
weather's good yeah
took some might bananas Oh hundred
percent 100 percent oh I don't know if I
have any day I didn't go shopping I even
got the market there over there dammit
that's alright you can still make do
with what you have and get something if
only extra hearts oh yeah check out
what's in those crates - behind you yeah
I'm hoping for some arrows sometimes
there's goodness
I don't need food oh there's a step up
there's a barrel too and thank you how'd
you get up here your nanners uh I got
sort of fire that's cool let's have some
wood no Loki tree I need to Flynn oh
there are I think it was up here wasn't
it there was the the rock there was like
a gemstone rock or that could look out I
think it was down there but we could
find one over here
I mean you have any fire to choose
[Laughter]
throw your boomerang I don't have them I
mean I did not choose it
oh I don't know but I like it
sorry voila
yeah I don't know why I didn't do the
bomb earlier sorry guys
my tea fish and mushrooms mm-hmm in this
sound booth is okay imagine you've just
held a banana in your hand what sound
would you make I guess
that's great that's great yeah yep thank
God Oh Peter nope crab
I could combine that voter all right
here we go final homestretch the ninth
inning
Rob handler ease up at bat pitching is
the he knocks your a of 4.20 what is
thinking okay
fear
what's fear smell like when people
seconds smell your fear what are they
talk about like oh my girlfriend says
that to me I don't know I can't all
right you've been given one in a hundred
odds what I believe in you Rob
always have always will yeah come over
here come over here come over here
oh no yeah come over here come on come
on come on come on
didn't you also just put those dudes in
the back row I actually don't like this
at all Peter what you doing I don't know
it's been a long day
there are explosive barrels some says if
we make banana noises oh oh that
Turkey's boss cheering about oh whoa Oh
what I'm here
I thought us on the other side man life
just got real complicated just leave the
island
maybe this Sox did this kind of sucks
[Music]
uh-oh he's gonna pick up those trees I'm
so frustrated by this I was snapping it
took me forever to fall asleep now the
Sun is up I'm a light sleeper
now you're getting restless leg syndrome
what's up Huey hot slug it's cool name
have you seen my friend damn Auto rock
they're so good they're like yeah
they're like the Brett Favre honestly of
hail-mary throwing beast in this game
God what do you think they are actually
spinning out their stomach lining no
mineral deposits sounds good souls
kill them with bombs yeah the problem is
that they have health regen so it's kind
of hard to keep that consistent Joey I'd
fun sighs I think I'm gonna say that no
leave Wow
Oh do they hear that no they're having a
party yeah they're having a party and we
show that guy right and we're just two
electric churches watching this Shea's
lounge it's so comfortable
we're just we just like to watch oh damn
dang again god
oh I don't know about that about what
that bomb looks like it hit them both
come on ran help us out
all right that's one bachelor party I
didn't like Phil anyway yeah yeah yeah
steak steaks
what are we gonna eat not yet yeah more
cheering his health isn't regen that's
kind of weird huh maybe it has to hit a
certain point before it regions get in
that water get out of here no one likes
you now so now it's reaching Jenny what
up I decided to name her age and from
that day on I want to get somewhere I
was wrong I was around the best line
what a lovely story and you tell all
right Peter
my friend next up I don't know what I
just want to do this go go go
I'm actually a pro double dip gube is
saying that double dipping is the worst
or double dippers are the worst
I'm so proud of you so I won't rate
all right so you definitely don't have
any arrows so if we were to confront
this jackass beast of a man we would
have a hard time this beast of a hey
next we'd have a hard time because we
can't shoot his puny little eye
there's penis so let's let's sneak it
it's the only thing I see fit
yeah and it's gonna be tricky you're
gonna have to throw weapons in his eye
that would be yeah that would be the
only way to stun them
that's double take care of yourself
oh yeah baby
no problem cool we did it we did it what
she did with a little help and we did it
some weapons but they first made for a
good stream a lot of help yeah yeah
still I mean there were some close calls
there where it seems like even with that
we weren't gonna do it
yeah I was gonna say [ __ ] that into the
ocean I I wasn't I wasn't gonna say it
cuz I felt like I was gonna jinx myself
but like I there are a couple moans or I
was felt like I was just gonna
accidentally kill myself yeah like
remember when I set off those four
explosive barrels yeah I remember it
like yesterday
all right well we gonna we gonna look at
this are we just gonna go for it yeah
let's let's officially finish it it's
officially finished do you mean by doing
it or [ __ ] closing up alright let's just
get it get it get it we'll take that
long back to double dipping yeah I'll
explain why I don't think it's a big
deal you know there's so many things
that we can't see right that are germs
that are back this goes for anything
then keep on it does go for anything
classic Mythbusters episode right they
wanted to determine okay if you keep
your toothbrush in a cabinet you will it
make any difference compared to whether
you keep it outside of the cabinet it
makes a small one but even if you keep
it inside of the cabinet and only take
it out to brush your teeth it's still
covered in [ __ ] yo [ __ ] particulate yeah
and you know what else
introducing things to your body
strengthens your immune system my
friends it's a double dip get to know
your friends better inside and out
I I think it's fine with acquaintances
yeah I mean but first impressions hey I
just got just finally got over my
malaria juicer you're out of toilet
paper it was a dip on a bus all day good
wash up after I go to the bathroom bed
own gets me this grimy moly wash your
hands before you eat
and then just life's a party dip to your
heart's content
you know I mean get a phantom I might
have it this is a good point use the
opposite end of the food Oh disappear
that's not double dipping dude well but
yeah you use other but you still held
that side well yeah if you're crafty
enough you can get an area that's
untouched depends on depends on V
utensil if you will the type of chip if
you will I treat my hand like a chip and
I dip it in and I just that is the
different levels of hands and I try to
open my mouth at once and get the ill
dip off I only do it with ranch dressing
though for some reason that's a grow
special ranch dressing dude like I've
been kind of steering away from that
stuff it is so gross but okay some ranch
dressing I will totally concede but
there is good very interesting out there
that is not like mass-produced thick
just like viscous crap yeah like a good
ranch dressing mm-hmm I need some of
that because I feel like the ranch I I
don't know with it what's a classic
brand but dude you leave that stuff out
for like 10 minutes yeah it turns into
where did we go yup we're not here gross
stuff oh no Peter you're going to I
tried to go to three camera Oh camera
it's not set up no set up just tisk
blame Tay that's okay you will just say
goodbye like this from the tiny corner
of the window we will I thank you all
for watching very much this was Triforce
thank you for your help you definitely
gave us the means to beat this Rob good
job thank you Peter
and thank you guys for the Hot Tips that
were probably made the stream because I
had a real good feeling that I don't
know if I would have done that I mean I
could I could do it like I had I could
have done it yeah not in a lot of time
we had for today but I think maybe next
week or maybe the following week anyways
down the road once I get enough hearts
to get the Master Sword we'll be
tackling those trials in master mode and
we'll we'll show it sure who's boss
with no cheats no cheats and I would
imagine we would probably do it in I
don't know that's that's more than like
you couldn't do we couldn't do all three
right maybe we'll do the last or or chip
away at it we should the middle section
I think you gotta like beat the trials
though I like the last section if we can
get there oh are you saying start at the
middle section yeah perfect
I like that okay come back tomorrow at
11 a.m.
John Luke psyche Joey what are they
playing do we know something funky you
said the Burger King game Oh sneak King
that's right we see the King yeah
they're gonna sneak their way into your
hearts and into your browsing history so
be sure to clear that before anyone sees
what you've been doing right it's a yeah
I think King is perverted it's a real
classic quotes quotes all right this has
been fun thank you all thank you enjoy
your week see you guys
Oh